you're called to create a
post-apocalyptic giraffe astronaut
generated Genghis Khan playing a guitar
solo pixel art generated
a man holding a delicious apple
uh what's with his hands
why can't AI art make hands it doesn't
matter what AI art model you use if you
have a man holding a delicious apple his
hands will look weird holding it why is
this so hard seems easy enough right
we've got this weird situation where AI
art can instantly make Abraham Lincoln
dressed like Glam David Bowie but
struggles with a woman holding a cell
phone
and just a weird glitch the struggle of
a IR with hands can actually teach you
something bigger about how AI art works
I mean what is so hard about this
I asked an artist who has taught
thousands of people how to draw hands
from imagination before someone becomes
or starts training
to be an artist like officially training
it's pattern recognition you just grow
up seeing a whole bunch of hands and you
start knowing what hands look like you
learn how things look by living in the
world and recognizing patterns
an AI is similar but has key differences
imagine an AI is like you but trapped in
a museum from birth
all the machine has to learn from are
the pictures and the little placards on
the side
Apple a red apple on a brown table
that's like the images it sees from the
web and the descriptions that go with
them it's similar to how you learn but
locked in that museum if you want to
understand an apple you can rotate it in
your hand you can watch it whatever you
want if AI wants to understand an apple
it has to find another picture of an
apple in the museum pattern recognition
has allowed Ai and people to draw decent
apples but the processes differ you
start training to become an artist and
now you're like okay now I have to learn
the rules and that's where it becomes
very different from how AI is learning
artists in order to draw something
complicated we tend to simplify things
into basic forms and so when you look at
a hand you pretty much have the big
blocky part of the Palm right you have
the front you have the back and then you
have the thickness and you can pretty
much just make that into like a square
with some thickness to it then an artist
can add all the style and texture and
detail they want
AI Works differently look at this hand
the shapes are bizarre but the AI has
done a great job showing the light and
texture here
remember the AI knows how things look
but not how they work so these patterns
in pixels are easy to understand
it never learned however that fingers
don't really Bend like this it doesn't
simplify the forms remember it's trapped
in a museum so it is just trying to
guess where hand-like pixels should be
without knowing how hands work like we
do
but listen I find this kind of
dissatisfying I mean I'm basically just
saying that AI can't draw hands because
it's not a person but AI also doesn't
know anything about construction and it
can still make a beautiful skyscraper in
New York City
so to understand this better I spoke to
two people who have worked with
generative art models ilundu is a grad
student whose heart is in robotics but
you know AI art is like a big deal now
so he got pulled into it because of how
popular these models have been in
generative art I've also been like being
a bit on that and I talked to Roy
shellcrott who has a super varied resume
but has been teaching about generative
art since 2018. good students that come
in uh that are trying to break those
models take them to the next level how
can you them helped me figure out three
big reasons not every reason but three
big reasons that hands are tough for AI
art models the data size and quality the
way hands Act and the low margin for
error
for the data size let's go back to the
museum idea the museum the robot hangs
out in it has a ton of rooms dedicated
to faces but not so many rooms for hands
that means it has less to learn from
just as an example available data sets
like Flickr HQ has 70 000 faces seventy
thousand and this popular one annotates
200 000 pics of celebrity faces for lots
of details like eyeglasses or pointy
noses
there are a ton of great hand data sets
that can really understand hands like
this one with eleven thousand hands but
these may not have been used to train
the AI that makes art
that data scarcity combines with the
quality and complexity of the data hand
data in the art museum isn't yet
annotated to show how they work like the
celebrities pointy noses what they say
is there's an image and there is a
person in the image and the person is
holding an umbrella you don't give the
machine a lot of Clues saying this is a
person holding the umbrella the thumb is
going from one side of the handle and
the fingers are curled and then the
thumb is covering the index finger but
not the other one
all that is made worse because hands do
lots of things compared to say faces so
there's a pretty common like portrait
photo face
there are a lot of these photos online
and the thing is everything's very well
centered right like eyes are always like
around here like there's always this
order that's not true of hands which can
do this and this and this I swear I'm
sober right now Stan mentioned this too
how many fingers do you see right now
like two or three so like it doesn't
know there's five because sometimes
there's two sometimes there's three
sometimes four sometimes five you can
see these problems with AI hands but the
jankiness is all over AI art just look
at horses you can also have like three
legs five legs six legs the model does
not learn to explain this because
there's too much diversity and it
doesn't have as much bias as we do okay
did you hear that last party said
good because it's really important
doesn't have as much bias as we do we
care a lot about hands and need them to
be perfect there is a low margin for
error
but because the model doesn't understand
hands hasn't seen many and because hands
act weird it makes pictures that are
like hands it's seen in the museum but
not an exact hand that's good enough for
a ton of stuff but not hands here let me
give you some examples come over here
so I typed make me a person with exactly
five freckles so this one's from dolly
two this one is from stable diffusion
and this one is from mid-journey so it's
like you know great job you've you've
got you know a red-haired person they're
more likely to have freckles but there
are not exactly five freckles here here
that doesn't really matter because we
see a freckly face but hands require
higher standards look at our Apple
holding man again I made three other
variations the hands are all weird but
don't look at them right now it changed
the shirt stripes the buttons the apple
style none of that matters because it's
stripe-like and button-like and apple
like but hand like isn't good enough
came away from this thinking a couple of
things AI art is basically bad at Art
we're just able to see it with hands and
B it's never going to get any better but
both of those things are a bit wrong I
will say that the newest air generator
to come out at the time this video is
mid Journey version five and they made
some progress with hands for sure but it
it's not totally fixed yet don't tell
the AI to hold an umbrella
I think they're like spending lots of
time on like some things that you
appreciate which is why you like the
images and a lot of stuff that you don't
actually even notice I think like for a
lot of natural scenery or something like
that I feel like model might be like
other people and they are working on two
things first they have the AI look at a
ton more pictures which requires more
computing power they're trying to solve
that on a big scale because if you want
to train on more than a handful of
images if you want to train or more than
100 images this would take tremendous
resources from you to retrain the model
itself the other solution might be to
invite more people into the museum
there's an interesting analog so like
have you heard of like Chachi BT the big
difference was that it basically used
human feedback
many many sentences and ask people to
rate which ones are good and which ones
are not good they basically fine tune
the model so that it would generate
sentences that are convincing to people
I guess it would require a lot of
engineering to get people to label so
much data but I think if we could just
get like people to link how good the
images are generated by these models
then like a lot of these issues will go
away actually because they're just
training the models to do what people
like
it's not just the hand teeth and abs
anything where there's like a pattern a
large amount of something it doesn't
know the rule of there are this many
because it's trained on different
amounts